welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and it's time to lick
that cookie like you're about to get
nooky because today we're getting into
squid game Netflix have just dropped off
first look at season 2 and in this video
we're going to be breaking all down and
talking about our theories we'll also be
going over what we know so far and
everything that's rumored about the show
this video will of course contain
spoilers so if you haven't watched
season 1 then I'm giving you the red
light green life for everyone else and
please hit the Thumbs Up Button if you
enjoy it will you survive until the end
will you last pass my [__] accent well
we're going to find out and with that
all the way let's get into squid Game
season
[Music]
2 okay so the teaser was released on a
trailer that Netflix Dro showcasing all
their upcoming shows and films this had
Eddie Murphy looking like he didn't want
to be there for Beverly Hills cob and we
also got our first H at Umbrella Academy
Season 4 amongst it we had our first Su
at squid Game season 2 which I believe
shows us the opening scenes of the
season that's me doing some guess work
but I can imagine they want to start
things immediately where we left off in
case you don't remember we end with Guan
winning the game and becoming a rich man
it was revealed that his friend ilam was
the one organizing the games and the
pair had one final bet before he passed
away guihan won and headed out to the
airport where he was planning to
reconnect with his daughter however he
saw the recruiter was still targeting
desperate people and ended up calling
the game organizers before he hit the
plane here he was demanding to know who
was running it with a person on the
phone ordering him to board it the
teaser picks up with him walking back
through the airport and the
conversations continue on the phone the
mysterious voice tells him he's going to
regret his choice with Guan promising
he'll find number four hanging up now
what we know about the season is that
it's going to be focused on the front
man who was an enigma wrapped up in a
mystery seeing the discovery of his
brother finding out he was an ex player
was a big reveal that we got in season 1
still though there's lots of things we
don't know such as how he ended up in
the position he's very much a sort of
prototype guihan as we also know that he
played the game too so season 2 could be
guihan potentially repeating the steps
and having to go through a process that
could recruit the front Men Yesterday we
also had a clear look at the show with a
giving a clear look at Gan returning to
the games of some sort his red hair was
no longer there and some time and
clearly passed you to everything down
his roots being back we're also getting
some falers on the front man too as we
had a portfolio pick with him holding
his mask I've always thought that it was
him on the phone at the end but in
rechecking things this is actually not
confirmed some places say it is and some
say it isn't but to me it is that guy
with illam out of the way he may have
taken over the position and now be even
further up the chain you also know that
from the cast list that his brother is
alive and thus we'll probably see them
going head-to-head obviously the way
they left things off wasn't on the best
terms but I do feel that is a path to
Redemption that wasn't a kill and blow
to be fair and thus I think there's a
possibility that he could pull him back
Netflix have confirmed confirm the
recruiters returning to who will'll
probably learn more about as well in the
first look images we could catch him
with guihan holding a gun which may even
be a game could be some Russian rouette
which would be a wild way to take things
I think the first season had a lot of
mystery to him and we didn't really see
what was going on with him and the
operation though we got a look at the
audience they were mainly hidden with
masks making me think there's a lot more
to explore there season 2 will obviously
have a much bigger budget so we can also
kind of dive into their lavish
Lifestyles Gan might even be tempted by
this unless let's be honest it would be
hard to resist be like not hitting the
thumbs up button when the guys asked you
to do it twice in the video and you'd
have to be a [__] dick uh but good
thing you mate and you've definitely
done it I feel like the front man may
have fallen into this temptation and on
the opposite side of this we'll see what
happens when someone goes against the
organization all the way back in 2022
The Hollywood Reporter interviewed the
creative team huge shout outs to V for
pulling this quad up and all my theories
might die quicker than this guy boom
dead they said we've seen many reactions
from from people about the show but we
don't want to make season 2 as a
response to those reactions the
philosophies we put in season 1 all
naturally extend to season 2 instead of
trying to meet the expectations of
viewers we just thought about the last
moments when guun turned away from
boarding the plane and thought about
what he will do next there will
naturally be a flow of events that will
lead all the way to the end of the
season we can't share any details yet
but you know that kean's become a
totally different person by the end of
season one so season 2 is going to be
about what the new gun's going to do and
how things will unfold with this new
kind of character on top of this we got
a tweet or an X or whatever which talked
about what was coming for season 2 it
said a whole new round is coming it took
12 years to bring the first season of
squid game to life last year but it took
12 days for squid game to become the
most popular Netflix series ever as the
writer director and producer of squid
game a huge shout out to the fans around
the world thank you for watching and
loving our show and now Guan Returns the
front man returns season 2 is coming the
man in the black suit with a daki might
be back back you'll also be introduced
to Y he's boyfriend CH Su join us once
more for a whole new round hang dong hu
now in addition to this we're of course
getting the games and we already know
what one it's going to be as the
creative team said we meet Yi's
boyfriend and I was thinking who the
[__] is that why well it's cuz I've
mispronounced all the names from season
one and I think I would remembered if I
got one right y he can bloody pronounce
that so I sto looking for who that was
it turns out Y is a doll from the red
light green light games so her
boyfriend's going to be similar sort of
game I guess maybe they'll switch it up
and change it so you go on red which I
can see confusing you if you're under
pressure a young he was inspired by 7
Korean textbooks and that's along with
ch Sue this is a student who appeared
alongside her and look at him look at
him complete psychopath mate and you
know he's going to go mental and start
killing everyone we'll also be getting
some players too with a teaser in the
first look of a woman holding up the
calling card now as for the release date
we're a bit unsure as nothing's been
teased about when it's coming out we do
know it's 2024 though so yeah sometime
this year Mt found this quote so shout
out to him cuz I was like ah mate I need
the video to be over 8 minutes so we can
put more ads in it and he was like I'll
get you somei and let you bump up the
runtime so shout outs to him anyway
here's what they said about the release
date from geo.tv Creator hang dong hu in
a letter to shareholders revealed
looking ahead despite last year's
strikes pushing back the launch of some
titles we have a big bold slate for 2024
audiences will be able to choose from
Hit returning dramas like the Diplomat
season 2 bridg in season 3 squid Game
season 2 and emperess season 2
unscripted Series like to of France
unchain 2 Love is Blind season 6 it's a
big quote it's loads of stuff and I'm
just going to skip over that so yeah the
way they phrase it though it's kind of
difficult to say exactly when they
mention grisal is already out and Avatar
drops in two weeks with them clearly
putting the big headers up top squid
game is the biggest series for the
platform and right now it's giving us
our biggest video on the channel never
have to work again mate pay the mortgage
and Views so I'm very excited to cover
season 2 mainly cuz I really enjoy the
first jeson not cuz I'm greedy even
though I did bump this up to 8 minutes H
but I can't wait to see what happens in
it does excite me that they're not
playing into what we expect though and
right now I'm going to turn it over to
you make sure you drop your craziest
theories below as I'd love to see what
you guys can come up with please drop a
like on the video and if you want to
support the channel as a member of the
spoiler Society then please click the
join button you get early access to
videos every week and it goes such a
long way to helping us out you want to
get some heavy spoilers merch you've
also got a t-shirt line located below
the video that will let you pick up all
kinds of Topsy all Theory time ones
House of dragon stuff Marvel te's and
more we drop new designs on there all
the time too so definitely keep an eye
out for them and thank you for your
support have you want some else to watch
you've got a breakdown on screen right
now going over everything we know about
stranger things season 5 lots of things
to talk about and that definitely head
over there and huge thank you for
checking out the video but out the way
I've been Paul you've been the best I'll
see you next time take care
peace
h